pour clément alexis dimitri et steven le
déclic c'est l'école de production leur
avenir ils le voyaient plutôt floue et
puis c'est devenu une été précis d'un
serrurier s'encastrer sur la tôle qui
vient dans la série
ok bon
monter une serrure steven colère la
prend directement à l'atelier de l'école
de production de dole avec juste son
certificat de fin d'études générales en
poche
difficile pour lui de trouver un maître
d'apprentissage voulait toujours
travaillé de la métallerie et je
trouvais pas de stage est du coup je
n'esquive ici c'est une école où l'on
apprend en faisant peur de vrais clients
un principe mis au point vers 1880 par
un ingénieur devenu prêtre le père louis
boisard jusque dans les années 90 les
écoles ne se développe quand ronald et
puis il ya sept huit ans jean yves
migneault découvre ces pédagogies alors
qu'il cherche justement une solution
pour des jeunes sortis du système
scolaire sans diplôme
enseignant et militant à atd quart monde
jean-yves millions se lance dans une
aventure
je pense que c'est un petit peu
paradoxale au sein des écoles de
production la manière dont s'est créé et
cofor on est un petit peu des pionniers
on va dire parce que ce sont des
enseignants des chefs d'entreprise des
banquiers c'est à dire des personnes
relativement différentes qui n'ont pas
forcément l'habitude de travailler
ensemble qui sont mis autour d'une table
et qui ont dit on va monter quelque
chose pour ces jeunes et ça c'était très
intéressant parce que cette synergie de
force de compétences a permis de monter
l'outil que l'ong que vous voyez et
cofor c'est le nom de cette école forme
aux métiers du pneu et de la métallerie
deux secteurs qui recherchent du
personnel à l'école de dole ce sont des
bénévoles qui assurent l'enseignement au
râtelier les parties du globe da we made
you trust 45 après 2007 partira en 2 22
ces calculs
c'est ce qui sera demandé à l'examen du
ceap et nicolas jacotot ou et
chaudronniers bien tous les vendredis
après-midi transmettre ses connaissances
techniques par conviction je vous
rejoins 2
les idées voilà c'est tout j'aurais aimé
savoir il continue quand j'étais plus
jeune
ah oui parce que je me sentais un peu
seul à l'école école de production
s'aiguise peut pas donc voilà le
professionnel transmet son savoir comme
il aurait aimé qu'on lui apprenne et
c'est ce qui convient à steven jeu au
collège écrêté cours faut que tu te
dépêcher on t'a pas tout le temps de
marquer pays si tu attends tous noté
correctement plus le temps de comprendre
que vous a dit le chef d'entreprise là
où vous avez fait votre stage en fait un
cas et voudrait bien voir que des jeunes
comment des jeunes comme steven écho
fort on a déjà formé 18 depuis sa
création
treize ont eu leur ca p dimitri
belleville fait partie de ceux qui ont
réussi leur diplôme il revient
régulièrement à dole ça fait trois ans
trois ans que je suis parti est
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous faites
est aujourd'hui je suis chez les
compagnons lui de voir dijon parce que
cette année je suis un cqp m
donc c'est un certificat de
qualification et après je partirai sur
un bts un parcours exemplaire son
histoire a même été reprise dans les
journaux et on vous la raconte demain